si vous êtes fan d'apple que vous avez
plein de produits d'apple que ce soit
que ce soit maggie nous que ce soit une
applewhite bref j'ai pas tout voulait
faire peut-être ne connaissez-vous pas
plein de petit secret sur la marque sur
l'historique de la marpa la marque elle
ne pas dire totalement elle a un peu
d'histoire il ya eu des personnages et
iconique à commencer par ses co
fondateur steve jobs donc je vous
racontais aujourd'hui pas moins de onze
secret d'apple jeu pour en avoir plein
d'autres jeux pour faire plein d'autres
vidéos d'ailleurs si ce concept de vidéo
vous intéresse dites le moi juste en bas
en commentaire on se crée sur apple pour
découvrir des choses que vous ne
soupçonnez pas vous ne soupçonnez que
vous ne soupçonnez pas et qu'il arrive
même plus à parler on se crée bref allez
on y va tout c'est
[Musique]
le premier truc je sais pas si vous avez
fait gars si vous regardez les
publicités d'apple ce soit si on les
monte sur les ipad sur tout ce que vous
voulez ce sont toujours les mêmes
horaires qui sont affichés toujours
regardé par exemple si je vous ai mis
une pub d'apple watch 10h09 10h09 10h09
10h09 on va retrouver toujours deux
horaires soient 10h09 soit 9h41 9h41 ça
correspond à l'heure à laquelle était
lancé le premier iphone en 2007 disant
même je n'ai pas la réponse mais alors
là effectivement vous lire il marqué 15
heures oui c'est une alarme mais la leur
c'est bien 10h09 et si vous continuez à
changer regarder on en a encore ici
10h09 on est ici à 10h09 10h09 10h09
10h09 10h09 j'en ai plein comme c'est
regarder à ses parieurs d'une
présentation j'ai bien 10h09 derrière là
on remonte un peu plus un peu plus dans
le temps sur l'iphone 6 aces 9h41 et
c'est toujours la même chose 10h09 ou
9h41 donc c'est un petit peu de détails
mais voyez de laver plan que je sais pas
si vous le saviez en tout cas on trouve
ça assez intéressant autre sujet qui est
intéressant si au niveau des
cofondateurs d'apple alors il ya
effectivement steve jobs ce que tout le
monde connaît pas je pense que tout le
monde connaît ya steve wozniak qu'on
appellera rose et ya ronaldo wayne alors
ronaldo wayne son histoire elle est
assez intéressante avec apple parce
qu'ils étaient plus âgés que les deux
autres il faut savoir qu'à l'époque où
ils ont créé apple steve jobs avait 21
ans bose 24 ans c'est donc assez jeune
et notre bon rooney n'était pas contre
lui plus âgées sauf que au début quand
ils ont lancé la boîte et bien steve
jobs a commencé à contracter des prêts
pour pouvoir développer apple sauf que
ça ronald uniflip un peu parce qu'il
disait ouhlala ouh là là où la lâche
landreau le seul solvables et c'est moi
que les banques vont venir chercher pour
venir payer ensuite les dettes et
risquent de payer avec mon patrimoine
personnel donc ce bon vieux ronaldo ap
ap ap non non non non non deux jours
après il a revendu ses parts à hauteur
de 800 dollars et bah oui c'est les 10%
du capital qu'il avait apportés il est
récupérer ses billes à fait aller les
gars chao est terminée moi je veux pas
prendre ce risque là bon et on estime
qu'aujourd'hui s'il avait conservé ses
parts il aurait une petite fortune de
peu près 200 milliards de dollars c'est
sûr quand on regarde dans le passé on se
dit pourquoi pourquoi mais à ce
moment-là peut-être qu'on aurait été
nombreux aussi à faire ça voilà bon bas
valais comme quoi des fois ça se tient
pas grand chose le troisième secret est
intéressant il faut savoir que l'iphone
qui a été lancé en 2007 n'était pas le
premier téléphone sorti par apple enfin
pas exactement en 2005 c'est à dire deux
ans avant le lancement de l'iphone apple
s'était associé à motorola pour sortir
ce smartphone il s'appelle le rockeur eu
un il était construit sur une base 2 398
de motorola you took était vraiment
novateur pour l'époque c'est que vous
aviez 512 mégaoctets de mémoire qui vous
permettait de mettre jusqu'à 100
chansons alors ça peut paraître
complètement ridicule aujourd'hui quoi
sans chansons dans un téléphone mais à
l'époque c'était lourd eu de lettre et
d'ailleurs même quand l'iphone est sorti
donc c'était le premier téléphone avec
100 chansons inclut d'ailleurs à vous le
voyez les brochets sera powerbook
d'apple alors ont récupéré les chansons
n'ont pas en bluetooth mais en filaire
il fallait se brancher aux côtés le côté
sur l'itunes music store ont récupéré
ses morceaux au format assez est ce
qu'on peut muter d'avoir 100 morceaux
dans la poche très facilement et à
l'époque croyez moi c'était
révolutionnaire bon et on comprend aussi
pourquoi apple s'est dit non en fait on
va faire autrement on va faire un iphone
ça sera mieux je vous assure quatrième
secret l'iphone a failli ne jamais
s'appelait l'iphone non pourquoi parce
que iphone était déjà une autre marque
déposée par une autre boite c'est cisco
met un peu la 10è on en a rien à faire
on va l'appeler ait quelque chose on va
l'appeler iphone ils ont donc sorti leur
iphone ça leur a fatalement valu un
procès pour ça s'est arrangé à l'amiable
j'imagine que petit chèque est parti du
côté de chez cisco pour pouvoir ensuite
utiliser la marque ou pourquoi pas
racheté la marque iphone autre astuce
qui est assez marrante c'est la
cinquième je sais pas si vous le savez
mais steve jobs lorsqu'il a voulu créer
l'ipod il voulait quelque chose de petit
miniaturisés au maximum et 20 autres
steve jobs il prenait son iphone est il
le seul un aquarium est temps qu'il y
avait plein de bulles qui remonte et les
on peut encore miniaturisés on va
miniaturisés on va faire plus petit qu
imaginé à l'époque vous avez des
ingénieurs qui travaillent christian
garde steve notre nouveau produit fait
moquer dans l'aquarium
faire assez marrant 6e secret que je
trouve vraiment marrant c'est en fait le
nom macintosh ça vient d'où et bien en
fait ça vient des pommes macintosh à
vous emmener sur wikipédia vous voyez
les pommes macintosh alors si vous
voulez regarder la fiche des pommes
macintosh et bien écoutez alesi bon
courage et elle est disponible sur
wikipedia en fait les pommes macintosh
c'était les pommes préférées de jef
raskin qui était à l'origine du projet
macintosh et qui du coup la baptiser
alors j'imagine qu'il ya eu des amas les
désaccords qui ont rappelé leurs
ordinateurs macintosh je trouve ça assez
marrant 7e secret se trouve assez dingue
pendant des mois les équipes ont
travaillé à créer ce qui allait être le
futur du téléphone le futur du
smartphone en tout cas vu par apple
l'iphone avant même le lancement du
premier iphone pendant des mois et sont
de bosser dessus un jour steve jobs est
arrivé à fait ok vous avez bien bossé
les gars c'est bien ce que vous avez
fait bon ben maintenant on doit tout
reprendre à zéro à tout refaire on va
refaire complètement le design c'est
complètement dingue de dire attendez
c'est à dire que tu as supervise et a vu
les projets un moment tu te dis ouais en
fait c'est pas mal mais non je pense que
c'est parce qu'il faut faire on va faire
différemment et donc des avis pour
bosser dessus pendant des mois et le
patron qui est le visionnaire dit ouais
mais en fait non on va te reprendre
imaginez vous à la place des mecs je
pense qu'ils ont dû devenir fou mais bon
au final ce qui sont sortis a cartonné
et a écrit en tout cas l'avenir est là
où on en est aujourd'hui au niveau de la
téléphonie mobile au niveau du
smartphone donc comme quoi il fallait
peut-être le faire en tout cas je ne
sais pas mais je serais curieux de voir
à quoi devait ressembler initialement
l'iphone pour que steve jobs 10 en fait
non ce n'est pas ça qu'on va faire on va
faire autant dans ces lettres quand même
assez différent j'imagine 8e secret
c'est le nom apple parce que tout au
début on imagine qu'apple n'est pas
apple apple n'est pas connu mais sont
quand même sortis leurs bois qu'ils
l'ont appelé apple ça leur a valu
quelques petits pour des cette histoire
avec apple corp apple corp était tenue
parquet par les beatles c'était
l'entreprise des beatles et les beatles
ont fait ou font en tout cas alors
représentant leurs ayants droit où j'en
sais rien on en fait non vous n'allez
pas appeler votre boîte apple nour
s'appelle déjà apple apple corp dont
vous allez pas vous appelez apple et
puis il ya eu des procès ça s'est fini
par un arrangement disant ok ok vous
allez vous appelez apple mais par contre
vous n'allez jamais rien à faire dans le
domaine de la mue vous ne sortirez aucun
produit en lien avec la musique ça
c'était à l'époque il faut croire que ça
c'est pas réellement passé comme ça par
la suite 9e secret intéressant c'est
l'ipad avant même que l'iphone soit
lancé l'ipad pour steve jobs était la
taupe priorité le produit qu'il voulait
sortir mais faute de trouver comment le
travail et d'un point de vue marketing
s'est dit bon en fait on va commencer
par l'iphone ça me paraît plus évident
il ya des besoins au moins comme ça il
ya un vrai marché et puis on le voit ils
ont sorti l'ipad quelques années après
qu' aujourd'hui en tout cas est un vrai
succès le dixième secret concerne les
magasins la présence des produits apple
dans les magasins et notamment les
téléphones steve jobs n'est pas la façon
dont les magasins présenter les produits
apple la façon dont les vendeurs les
wendel et présenter les proposent au
public il les considérait pas assez
formés voir pas formé du tout donc il
est décidé de bons vieux style de dire
ok ok ils sont sympas on va faire
différemment on va faire nos propres
magasins et on va vendre nos produits
comme on les entend comme on l'imaginé
et ils ont d'ailleurs créé une nouvelle
façon de faire des magazines des façons
d'apporter du service en magasin et il
faut croire que ce type là dessus il
avait aussi un coup d'oeil et puis le
deuxième point gentil wells a sonné je
ne t'ai rien demandé les séries syrie
tout écouter le bon vieux ce type se
dire ok ok bon ok doria syrie ça tombe
plutôt bien parce que justement on va
parler de syrie c'est pas fait exprès
c'est le onzième secret en fait syrie au
début n'a pas du tout été créé par apple
siri vient d'une boîte norvégienne
c'était donc une boîte indépendante
jusqu en avril 2010 date à laquelle
apple a racheté la boîte qui s'appelle
qui s'appelait en tout cas si 200
millions de dollars a quand même un
petit montant coquet et d'ailleurs je
passe si vous en souvenez mais s'il y
est intégré pour la première fois à
l'iphone 4s dont vous pouvez retrouver
l'époque jusqu'en 2010 votre application
syrie dans votre app store est en fait
le nom syrie il vient d'où c'est le
signe haut de la boîte syrie dagg qui
cloche je pense que je prononce pas trop
mal qui donne la dénomination exacte de
syrie alors je vous lis je les écris ici
femme magnifique qui vous mène vers la
victoire rihanna est d'ailleurs il avait
dit je cite une fois de plus j'avais
travaillé avec une femme qui s'appelait
syrie en norvège je voulais que ma fille
s'appelle syrie et puis le nom de
domaine était libre bah quoi plutôt pas
mal sauf que il a jamais eu de fille
d'agde il a eu un fils dont il n'a pas
appelé syrie et d'ailleurs il faut
savoir que steve jobs je n'aimais pas le
nom syrie mais bon faute de mieux il l'a
conservée parce que quand on va lancer
le nom d'une intelligence artificielle
dans le monde entier il faut déjà que ce
nom puisse être prononcée dans le monde
entier soit simple soit cours est donc
bon ils ont gardé syrie faute de mieux
voilà pour ces onze secret sur apple je
peux vous en faire d'autres un des
vidéos sur les secrets d'apple parce que
y'en a plein air une histoire qui est
tellement depuis 1976 donc si vous
souhaitez d'être vidéos comme celle là
vous me dites en commentaire puis je
vous en parlerai on en fera d'autres et
on sera plaisir alors j'en ai fait
d'autres j'en ai fait sur rush et omis
j'en ai fait ça ça me touche je préfère
sont pas d'autres marques dites moi si
ça vous intéresse en bas en commentaire
et si oui quelle marque vous
souhaiteriez que j'aborde et que je vous
donne tous les secrets de la marque moi
je vous embrasse vous donne rendez vous
très bientôt pour notre sol vous de vous
de vos proches des gros bisous le
printemps arrive c'est plutôt chouette
on va en profiter les bisous d'amour ce
diabète
[Musique]